The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today,
what we want to do
is talk about something at a
much higher scale than what
we've thought about through
most of this semester.
And that's probably by design.
Over the course of
the semester, we
started with kind
of enzyme kinetics
or molecular binding
kind of events,
and we slowly built our way up
the larger and larger scales.
Now there's always this
question about whether we're
claiming that we really
understand how the higher
levels of organization
result from the lower level
interactions.
And I'd say, we definitely
don't understand all of it.
So you shouldn't come away
with that as the notion.
But at least one
thing that I think
is fascinating about this
area of systems biology
is that much of the framework
that we use to understand,
let's say, molecular scale
interactions or stochastic gene
expression, so these dynamics
at the smaller scale,
much of those ideas and
such certainly transport up
to these higher scales or
translate up to the higher
scales, where, in
this case, we're
using kind of master
equation type formulas
to try to understand
relative species abundance.
And so I think
part of what I like
about this topic of neutral
theory versus niche theory
and so forth in ecology
is that you can just
see how very, very similar
ideas, that we applied
for studying stochastic
gene expression,
can also be used to try
to understand why it is
that some species are more
common than others when you go
and you count them, in this
case, on an island in Panama.
Now, the subject
is, by its nature,
less experimentally
focused than much
of what we've done over
the course the semester.
And this is really
a topic the tends
to be a combination
of mathematical theory
with kind of careful counting of
species in some different areas
and trying to understand
what that means.
But it's an area
that there have been
a number of physicists involved
in over the last 10 years.
And I think that
it's fascinating,
because it does get to the
heart of what we are looking
for from a theory,
what kind of evidence
do we use to support a
theory or to refute it.
So I think there are a lot of
very basic issues about science
that come up when
we start thinking
about this question of
neutral theory in ecology.
And since it's, for many
of us, a totally new area
that we don't know
very much about,
you can come to it
with maybe fresh eyes.
And you don't have the
same preconceptions
that you would have for many
other models that you might
be more familiar with in the
context of molecular cell
biology.
So the basic question
that we're going
to try to talk
about today is just
the question of why is it that,
when you look out at the world,
you see that there
are some species that
seem to be abundant and
some that seem to be rare?
Are there other patterns
that are somehow universal?
And what kind of sort
of lower scale processes
might lead to the
patterns that we observe?
And I think that this paper
that we read is-- I mean,
it's not that it's.
Well, can somebody say what the
actual scientific contribution
of this paper was?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They
did a calculation.
PROFESSOR: They
But it's a little bit
more specific than that.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: They came up with
the closed form equation?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Basically, there was a model of
this neutral theory in ecology
that we're going to explain
or try to understand.
You can simulate the
model, but then there
are possible issues associated
with convergence or something
of those.
Although it's hard
to believe that
that's really such a concern.
But you can simulate that model.
What they did is
they just showed
that you could get an analytic-y
kind of expression for it.
It's not a super
analytic expression,
but, at least, it's not
a straight up simulation.
You kind of numerically
do something,
integrate something,
as compared to doing
the stochastic simulation.
So it's not that that,
in and of itself,
is what you feel like--
it's not what we necessarily
care so much about.
But I think that it's still
just a nice, short description
of the model and the
assumptions that go into it.
And you get a little
bit of a window
into the debate that's
going on between these two
communities of kind
of the neutral theory
guys and the niche
theory community.
So there's only one
figure in this paper.
And it's an example
of the kind of data
that we want to
try to understand.
So there's a particular
pattern in terms
of the relative
species abundance.
And we want to understand
what kind of models
might lead to that
observed pattern.
But given that there's just
one figure in the paper,
we have to make sure
that we understand
exactly what is being plotted.
And what I've found
from experience--
and, actually, even the
answer to the email question
that was sent out, I
think, was incorrect on one
of these things.
So we'll talk about
that some more.
So beware.
We'll figure it out.
But I think it's actually
surprisingly tricky
to understand what
this figure is saying.
But first of all, can
somebody describe not
what the figure is
saying but just what
the data is supposed to be?
Where do they get the data?
Anything that's useful?
AUDIENCE: They were on
an island ecosystem.
PROFESSOR: There's an island.
It's called BCI,
Barro Colorado Island.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So it's
a 50 hectare plot.
Does anybody know
what a hectare is?
AUDIENCE: It's a lot
more than a square meter.
PROFESSOR: It's a lot more than
a square meter, yes, indeed.
Yeah.
Is this an English
unit of measure?
This is the kind of thing
that I have to Google.
But it's one hectare is equal
to 10 to the 4 meters squared.
That's a good thing to memorize.
I
AUDIENCE: Exactly
or approximate?
PROFESSOR: I think it's exact.
I think I think it's an exact.
AUDIENCE: Then
it's a metric unit.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so apparently
it is a metric unit.
So the idea is that if you take
a 100 meters by 100 meters,
this is a hectare.
And there's 50 of them.
It's about like a half
a square kilometer
to give you a sense of
what we're talking about.
And what do they
do on this plot?
AUDIENCE: They count a certain
number as canopy trees.
So the trees that
are, like, really big.
PROFESSOR: And how do they
decide which trees to count?
Did they count every tree?
AUDIENCE: No, just the ones
that like formed the top layer.
PROFESSOR: I think that the
way that they decide-- OK.
Does anybody remember how
many trees were counted?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there are 21,457
trees in this 50 hectare plot.
They identify the species for
each one of these 21,000 trees.
And they assign them.
And they found that there
were 225 distinct species.
So this is really quite
an amazing data set.
Because I can tell you that I
would not be able to do this.
This was highly
skilled biologists
that can distinguish 225.
If they can identify
these 225, that
means they have to be able to
identify other ones as well.
And they did it
for 20,000 trees.
And indeed, Barro
Colorado Island
is one of the major Smithsonian
research institutes,
where they've been tracking.
They do this like
every five years or so,
where they do a census, where
they count all of the trees.
And they're also tracking many
other-- it's not just trees.
They're doing everything there.
AUDIENCE: Is there only plants?
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Is it only plants?
PROFESSOR: No.
So actually, I
visited BCI, and it
seemed like they were
studying all sorts of things.
And there were nice
looking birds there.
AUDIENCE: No, I
mean in this census.
PROFESSOR: In this
census, it's only trees.
And the way that they decide
which of the trees to do,
it's the ones that are more
than 10 centimeters DBH.
Anybody can guess
what DBH might mean?
It's actually diameter
at breast height.
So what they do is they walk
up to the tree with a ruler,
and then, if it's larger
than 10 centimeters,
then they count it.
You need to have some
threshold at the lower end,
otherwise you're
in trouble, right?
And there were plenty of trees
that satisfied this requirement
here.
Then what they do, for
all of these trees,
it's assigned to some species.
The basic goal of this
branch of biology or ecology
is to try to
understand the pattern,
from this sort of data,
where it comes from.
Or first describe
it, and then once you
have a description
of it, then you
can try to understand what
microscale processes might
lead to the pattern.
And the pattern is what's
plotted in figure 1.
It's the only
figure in the paper.
I have reconstructed
a rough version of it,
here, for you on the board.
But if you want a
more accurate version,
you can look at your paper.
Now, we want to make
sure that we understand
what the figure is saying.
So we will ask the
following question.
What is the most common
number of individuals
for a species in this data set?
The most common/frequent number
of individuals for a species
to have in this data set.
Now, it's maybe
worth just saying
something a little bit more.
So you notice that
they were not trying
to count the total number
of species, altogether.
And in general, all of this
field of relative species
abundance, to try to
understand them, what you do
is typically take
one trophic level.
So some of the
classic studies were
of beetles in the Thames River.
The idea is that it's
some set of species
that you think are
going to be interacting,
maybe competing,
with each other,
in some way, in the
sense that they're
maybe eating related things and
being eaten by related things.
And so in this case,
these are the trees
in Barro Colorado Island.
And you can imagine
that this is useful.
The fact that it's trees
instead of something else
means that you can actually
track the individuals
over time.
And when you go
to the island what
you see is that all the trees,
they're wrapped by some tag.
And presumably, they
have some system
to tell you which species
that is so that they
keep records of everything.
But the question is, what's
the most common number
of individuals for
species in the data set?
Do you understand what
I'm trying to ask?
And we're going do
approximate, so we'll say.
Or this, can't determine.
We want to know, what is the
mode of this distribution
of the number of individuals
for each of these species?
Do you understand the question?
I'm going to give you 20
seconds to look at this.
AUDIENCE: Should we just
hold a blank piece of paper?
PROFESSOR: Oh, we
don't have our-- ah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You know, the
TA always lets me down.
All right, yeah.
So you can do A, B,
C, D, E. Are we ready?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You can just
do this if you're not.
But given this was the
only figure in the paper,
and that this is a basic
property of the distribution,
I'm sure that you figured that
out last night, anyways, right?
Especially since it was
one of the questions
in the [INAUDIBLE].
So you presumably already
thought about this question,
right?
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Ready,
three, two, one.
I'd say we got a lot of B's.
So it seems like B is the most.
So this, we'll put a
question mark here.
Can somebody verbally
say why their neighbor
said that the mode of the
distribution is around 30?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The tallest bar.
PROFESSOR: The tallest
bar there is around 30.
That's a very
practical definition.
So that's normally what
we mean by the mode.
There is a slight
problem in all of this,
which is that this
thing is plotted
in a very kind of funny way.
So if you look at the
figure, what you'll see
is that it's number
of individuals.
And down here, it
says, log2 scale.
Now, when we say the mode,
what we're wondering about
is that, if you just take the
most typical kind of species
of tree that's there,
how many individuals do
we think there should be there?
Of course, typical
is hard to define.
We can talk about mode,
median, mean, et cetera.
But the most common
number of individuals
for a species of the data
set ends up not being 30.
It ends up being 1.
And we will try to
reconstruct this right now.
Because you have to do
a little bit of digging
to figure out what is
being plotted here.
But it's not the raw data.
The problem here is that this
is on this log scale, where
the bins here are growing
kind of geometrically
or exponentially, whatever,
as you move to the right.
So over here, this thing
only contains one real bin.
And actually,
we're about to find
it's half a bin,
which is even weirder.
Whereas out here,
this is maybe 30 bins.
So the number of species that
we're going to put in this bin
is everything between around
20 something up to 50 or so.
The number of kind
of true bins that
end up in each of
these plotted bins
is going to grow geometrically
as we move to the right.
So this is a very funny
transform of the data.
And indeed, I think it's
always nice to just, in life,
you always plot
the raw data first.
And then what you can do
is then you can do funny.
There's a reason to
plot it this way.
Because this is where they
get this idea that this might
described as described
as a log normal.
The idea is, if you
take a log of the data,
then you get something
that looks like a normal.
But you always plot
the raw data first.
So let's try to figure out
what the raw data looked like.
And now what we're
going to do is
we're going to have real
scalings, honest to goodness
numbers.
Now the number of
species you get still.
So this is asking, how
many different species
do we see with one member
or with two members
or with three, four, et cetera?
And I don't know how
far we're actually
going to be able to get.
But in this one
figure, in our paper,
they tell us what
the histogram means.
So the first histogram
bar represents what
they call phi 1 divided by 2.
Phi 1 was the number of species
observed with one member, which
means that even this
first plot bar is not
the number of species observed
with a single individual.
It's half of that.
You can argue about
the consistency
of how these things
should be, but that's
what this thing's plotted.
And it looks like it was nine,
here, so this should be 18.
So I'm going to put up here,
here's a 20 and here's a 10.
Right, so here is an 18.
Now, what do they say?
This bin represents
phi 1 divided
by 2 plus phi 2 divided by 2.
So they took the
number of species
where they saw just a single
individual plus the number
of species where they
saw two individuals,
and they added those
and they divided by 2.
That's this number.
We're not going to go
through this whole process,
because it's a
little bit tiresome.
But I've already
done it for you.
So I'm going to plot a few
of things to get you there.
And so I calculated
it was 19, 13, 9, 6.
It becomes ill-determined
once you get out here,
in the sense that we
don't have enough.
It's not uniquely specified
going from that to that
as it has to be.
But I calculated it.
It's around 5, in
here, for a few.
And somewhere in here,
it's going to go into 4.
And then this might go down
to 3, and then deh, deh, deh.
Now, if you look at this and
the rapid rapid fall-off,
do you think that you're
going to find any species that
have more than 20 individuals?
We're going to vote.
So you see this falling-off?
So let's say that I've
just showed you this,
and I haven't yet
calculated the rest,
do we think that there's going
to be any species with more
than 20 individuals?
Greater than 20
individuals, question mark?
1 is yes.
2 is no.
It's going to be yes, no.
Ready, three, two, one.
So we got some 2s.
So I'd say that most
people are saying, no.
Look at this fall-off.
They're not going
to be any species
with more than 20 individuals.
Although we already
know that there
are many species with
more than 20 individuals.
So this plot is
useful for something.
You can see that there are.
And we know exactly
the number of species
that have more than 20
individuals, roughly.
So those ones are all in these.
So you can see that there
are hundreds of species
with more than 20 individuals.
And indeed, it looks like there
were two or three species that
had more than 1,000
individuals or 1,500
or whatever the
cutoff there was.
So this distribution
starts out rather high
but then falls quickly.
And out here, it's going
to be very, very sparse.
So there's going to be a
bunch of numbers in here
where there's not any
species in the histogram.
And then out there, there's
going to be one, right?
And indeed, you have
to go really far out.
Because there's one
species out there
that has a couple thousand.
And indeed, the mean number
of individuals per species
has to be around 100.
We know how to calculate a mean.
This divided by this
is just short of 100.
So the mean number of
individuals in a species
is around 100.
The mode is one.
And the median?
Well, ready?
We decided this was the mode.
Where is the median going to be?
Is it going to be A, B, C, D?
Ready, three, two, one.
Indeed, this tells you pretty
clear where the median is.
This thing is indeed
around the median.
Because you can say, oh,
it's about the same numbers
to either side.
So the median is around here.
And I told you where
the mean was, again.
You guys remember?
Ready, three, two, one.
Mean, uno.
Mean.
So this is a very, very
funny distribution.
I guess I want to
highlight that.
And I think it's
not at all what you
would have expected somehow.
At least, if you had described
this measurement process to me,
if you told me that
you went to this island
and you counted 20,000 trees,
I don't know how many species
I would have guessed.
But OK, 220, it's reasonable.
Well, I would have guessed it
would have looked something
like this on a linear
scale, maybe, right?
You know, that there would be a
bunch of them around 50 to 100
and some would go couple
hundred, some of them.
So I guess I would have
thought that the mean, mode,
median would all be kind
of a more similar thing.
But this is just not
the way the world is.
It's not just on BCI.
People, for hundreds
of years, have been
studying these distributions.
And things that look like this,
with extremely long tails,
this is what people see.
Now you can argue about
exactly how fast it falls off
and whether it's different
on a mainland or an island.
But this basic feature, that
rare species are common,
this seems to be just
that's what you always see.
This is the thing that
you have to remember,
rare species are common.
And I think that this is
the basic, surprising thing
in this whole field.
And the ironic
thing is that even
after spending all this
time reading about theories
to describe these distributions,
it's still very possible--
and I would say, based on
the statistics, this year
and past years, it's
not just possible,
but it is the
standard outcome-- is
that after reading
this paper, you
do not realize that the
distribution looks like this.
You somehow still think that
it looks-- you kind of still
think it's like a linear scale,
where the typical species has
this, where the mean,
median, mode are all
about the same thing.
So I guess always plot the raw
data in an untransformed way.
There are theoretical
reasons why it might
be nice to plot it like this.
But be very careful
about what you're doing.
Because then you're left with
a mental image of a histogram
that looks like this.
And that's very, very dangerous.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
matter [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE] the aggregate
data in bins like that.
And I mean, sure, exactly
one species is the mode,
but do you really want the--?
PROFESSOR: I understand
what you're saying.
It's just that there's
a qualitative aspect
to the data, which is that
most species are very rare.
And this is something that
I think is surprising.
I think it's deep.
And it's something that
you do not get realized.
AUDIENCE: Most species
have more than 16.
I mean, it depends
what you mean by rare.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Look at the way
that the distribution is away
from trend.
AUDIENCE: That's a good point.
But the species
density is clustered
around the low numbers.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: But actually most
species have more than 30.
PROFESSOR: Maybe
the surprising thing
is that just if you
take-- the mean is 100.
And so I would've thought that,
if you plot number of species
as a function of the
number of individuals,
given those numbers, I would
have guessed, OK, here's 100.
I would have guessed--
here's 50, so just
to highlight that this is 150.
So linear scale, I
would have guessed
it would look something like
that, maybe larger than Rudin
or something.
AUDIENCE: What would that
look like in a log2 scale?
It would look like It's
like the log of [INAUDIBLE]?
So it goes up really
fast and then--
PROFESSOR: So this thing
would be kind of like shoom.
I mean all the
weight would be in.
It would be like all here plus
a little bit on each of these.
AUDIENCE: But yeah.
I don't think it's
actually that different.
The only thing that's different
is the tail on the left.
PROFESSOR: And the
tail on the right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
a little bit longer.
PROFESSOR: No, it's
lot longer, right?
Because this thing, all of the
weight is between 50 and 150,
which means that
all of the counts
are basically going to
be these two, basically.
Because this thing
comes out either way.
So in this case, if you
take that histogram put it
on this kind of scale,
you end up with two bars
up high, nothing outside.
So it's a very
different distribution.
And it's not to say that this
is a ridiculous thing to do.
It's just that.
But the problem is
that your mental image
of what the distribution
looks like ends up
being incorrect, in
the sense that you
have a qualitatively different
sense of what's of what's
going on.
And if you go up to 10 species,
here, and 10 is way down here.
If this is what it
looked like, there
would be essentially no species
with fewer than 10 individuals.
But if you come over here
and you add it up here.
It's like a mean of 6
times 10 is 60 out of 200.
A quarter or a third of the
species on this plot of land
have fewer than 10 individuals.
And 10 is really a
very small number.
Well, rare species are common.
I think it's a true description
of the observed distribution
here and elsewhere.
And it's not something
that you appreciate
or realize when you
plot it in that way.
AUDIENCE: But you can get this
information from that plot.
PROFESSOR: No, I agree.
You can get it.
But it was only 10%
of the group got it.
Right, the fact that you can
get it-- right, it's possible.
But you don't get it.
That is a practical statement.
Yeah, I'm not dead set
against this distribution.
It's just that it
makes everybody think
something that's not true.
So if you think that that's
OK, then I can't help you.
It's OK, but it's
just you have to be
careful is my only statement.
And I very much want
you to take away.
Because I this is an accurate
description of the data.
Rare species are common.
And one of the readings-- I
think it was in this paper,
maybe it was a different
one that I was reading.
Even Darwin, when talking about
this, commented on this fact
that rarity of species is
somehow a typical event.
AUDIENCE: And common
species are rare.
PROFESSOR: And common species
are rare, that's right.
This distribution is
hugely, hugely skewed.
These are the measurements.
It's good to look at them
in both of these ways.
Because you can't even plot
the data on a linear scale.
So that's a good
reason for doing it.
But I think it's good to have
both of these pictures in mind.
What we want to do is to talk
about two classes of models
that give something
that's essentially
this log normal distribution.
So on a log scale it looks
normally distributed,
approximately.
And those two models
are going to be
kind of a niche-based
model and a neutral model.
Can somebody, in words,
explain what they maybe
see as the difference
between this niche
and a neutral kind of approach?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Every species is--?
PROFESSOR: In which one?
AUDIENCE: In niche.
PROFESSOR: In the niche theory,
the species are different.
So it seems like a
ridiculous statement.
Do you believe that
species are different?
We can vote, yes or no.
Ready, three, two, one.
Yeah.
Well, somebody's been convinced
by the neutral theory.
It's clear that
species are different.
And the question is which
patterns in the data
do you need to
invoke differences
in order to explain?
And I think that one,
maybe, theme that's
come out of this relative
species abundance literature
and the debates between the
neutral and the niche guys
is just that this
distribution is
less informative
of the micro scale
or individual kind
of interactions
then you might have thought.
Because multiple
models can adequately
explain such a pattern.
In all areas, we
have to remember
that you make an observation,
and you write down a model
that explains that observation.
So what you do is you
write down a model.
And writing down a
model, what that means
is that you make some
set of assumptions.
And then you look to see
what happens in that model.
And if the model is consistent
with the data, that's good.
But it doesn't prove that
the assumptions that went
into the model are correct.
And this is a trivial statement.
And I've said it before.
You have to tell yourself
this or remind yourself
of this kind of once a month.
Because it's just such an
easy thing to forget about.
Now, the niche
models indeed assume
that the species are different.
And that's reasonable.
Because we think it's true.
But then, of course, there
are many different ways
of capturing those differences.
And then you have to decide
whether the assumptions there
are reasonable or whether
they're necessary, essential.
In the context of
the niche models,
we're going to think about the
so-called broken stick models.
So basically, you get
log normal distributions
when there's some sort of
multiplicative-type random
process that's being
added together.
You get normal
distributions when
you have sums of random
things going together.
This is the central
limit theorem.
But when you have
multiplicative kind
of errors or random
processes coming together,
you get log normal
distributions.
And I want to highlight that
that does not necessarily
have to tell you so much
about the biology of it.
Because a classic
situation where you get log
normal distributions is if you
take a stone and you crush it.
You can do this
experiment at home.
And then you measure the mass
distribution of the resulting
fragments.
And the distribution
of mass is log normal.
Just take a stone, grind it
under your boot or hammer it,
just kind rub it right in.
You'll get you'll get some
distribution of fragments.
For each of the fragments,
measure the mass, and, indeed,
you end up getting a
log normal distribution.
Because there's some sense
that what's happening
is that you take a larger
mass, you break it up randomly,
and then the resulting
fragments, at some rate,
each of them you
break up randomly.
and the small ones
are maybe kind of
less likely to get broken
up as the big ones,
so then the small ones can
still get even smaller.
But then there's going to be,
at some rate, some very large
ones.
So such a process ends up--
I mean it's not biology.
This is just something about
the nature of the breaking
up of this physical object.
And indeed, the basic
idea behind many
of the niche models that give
you a log normal distribution
is equivalent to
crushing a stone
and measuring the
resulting distribution.
I'll describe what
I mean by that.
Typically, the
broken stick models,
they say there's
some resource axis.
This is a resource axis.
And this could be, for example,
where you're getting food from.
Now, we're going to have
to divide up this resource
access among some number
of different species.
And what we're
going to assume is
that the number of
individuals in the species
is proportional to the
length of the resource axis
that it's able to capture.
And I want to make
sure I find my notes.
I want to highlight this.
This comes from
MacArthur in the 1950s.
MacArthur and it's 1957.
So we imagine there's this
homogeneous resource axis.
We're going to break
it up into N segments.
And the abundances are
proportional to the length.
And the idea is that, if you
just break this up randomly,
so let's say you just draw
N minus 1 lines randomly,
or N minus 1 points
randomly here.
Now you have N species with
N different abundances.
The question is does
that give a log normal?
We'll say N minus
1 random points.
Do you understand what I mean.
You sample uniformly once,
sample uniformly twice.
You do that N minus 1 times,
and now you have N and deh deh.
And then we say, OK,
the first species
has this many individuals.
The second has this one.
The third is this
one, et cetera.
The question is
does random points,
does that lead to a log normal?
Yes and no.
Let's think about
this for 10 seconds.
N minus 1 random points,
log normal distribution,
ready, three, two, one.
So I'd say that we have
a majority are saying no.
Can somebody say why that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because
it's something else.
That's fair.
But can you say
qualitatively why it is
that this is not going to work?
AUDIENCE: You can't
have very long gaps.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That is it's going to
be very unusual that you
get a very long gap.
What about the other end?
AUDIENCE: Also a very long tail.
PROFESSOR: Now I'm a
little bit worried.
I think that that's true, right?
Well, I'm going to say
that you're not going
to get this super long ones.
I think that the
distribution might still
be peaked at short values.
No?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Random?
If we were just traveling
along this resource axis,
at a rate that's kind of
exponentially distributed,
like Poisson rate,
we just dropped
points, that's something
very similar to this random--
AUDIENCE: It said we're
limited in the number--
PROFESSOR: No.
Is that not true?
AUDIENCE: Your
sample [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm a little bit
worried that I might be-- now,
I'm not 100% confident.
Depending on how I look at this,
I get different distributions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But I think the
first thing that he said,
where you just say, I'm going
to pick N minus 1 points--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --is a different
thing than going along the axis
and exponentially
dropping ones along.
PROFESSOR: I agree
it's different.
AUDIENCE: I don't think that
would be the idea simulated,
because you would be
very likely to just get
this giant thing at the
end when you're finished.
AUDIENCE: What you could
do, you could go on
to draft N plus 2 points.
PROFESSOR: No, I think--
AUDIENCE: These scales that
are your two end points
[? are doubled. ?]
PROFESSOR: Because I
think that the probability
distribution does grow.
I think that I'm going
to side with you.
So we've decided
that there are not
going to be as
many short sticks,
and there's not going
to be as long sticks as
compared to a log normal.
Do we agree with that?
At least we agree that it's
not going to be a log normal.
So you're not going to
get this huge variation
of some very long sticks
and some very short ones.
Now, the question is how would
you change this sort of model
in order to generate
a log normal?
And the answer is that
what you have to do
is you have to what is called
some niche hierarchy or so
some hierarchical breaking.
Just like what led to the
stone giving you a log normal
is that you have to have
some successive process
of breaking things.
So this is what they call
some hierarchy model.
And then they key thing
is that it's sequential.
You have your resource axis.
First, you have some
rule for breaking it up.
It could be that you
just sample uniformly
or some other
probability distribution.
And the way that you
might think about this
is via-- just everything
up on the board
is so nice and useful.
I feel bad getting rid of it.
This thing is not true, so
I don't mind erasing it.
So let's imagine some bird
community in the forest.
And we're going to
think about where
is it that the birds are
getting their grub or their food
to eat.
First, well, now the
axis is somehow vertical.
You could divide them up
into the ground foragers
as compared to the tree
foragers in terms of where
they're getting their food.
And you say, oh, well, how much
of the food is on each side?
Oh, well, we'll say 30% is on
the ground, 70% is on the tree.
This is along the stick.
You cut the stick
in some way, or you
break the stick in some way.
But then within
the tree foragers,
you'd say, well, the
resources might be separated.
And this is really
like speciation,
a species is in the
niche, the species
are focusing on
different niches.
So you'd say, oh, some are
going to focus on the trunk,
some will focus on branches.
And again, this
part of the stick
is now broken or divided among
different resource locations
with some amount.
But then also, you're
going to get speciation
in different directions
here, because there's
both the surface-- I don't
know if you guys have ever
eaten grubs-- but there's
the surface grubs,
and then there's also
the sub-bark grubs.
And so you kind of do this
process multiple times,
where you kind of pick
different branches
and break them to
divide up the niche.
And then you end up with a
log normal type distribution.
And this is a similar process
to the crushing of the stone,
because the idea is that there's
sequential breaks of the stone.
So the stone first breaks
into maybe simply two
or it could be three.
First, there's one breaking.
And then one of
them is broken more.
So given this
process, you end up
getting a log
normal distribution.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you also have a
distribution of like how far.
Because I guess there
are two questions.
Like when you break your
stick, you assume, somehow,
that you uniformly break it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
A lot of work has gone
into the question of how it
is you should break the stick.
Given that you have this
tree foraging stick.
On a practical level,
what they do is
they ask, well, what probability
distribution gives you the best
agreement with the data?
Is it uniform?
Or is it, oh, it's
broken like this?
And in some cases
people say, well, it's
actually tilted on one side.
Well, in the context
of a succession
and some other
environments, there's
an idea that, if a species
first gets somewhere,
they can kind of
monopolize a larger
fraction of the resources
then if it's divided kind
of an equally at the beginning.
And that's going to effect where
this probability distribution
is going to break each one.
But there's always this
question about how constrained
are the notions and so forth.
And I'm agnostic on that point.
AUDIENCE: But you also need
distribution for how many times
it breaks [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's just that, if
you do this process,
it's like a central limit
theorem type result.
So you have to do it enough
times so that you get
to some limiting distribution.
And then you could
keep on doing it.
In the end, we always say
that species abundance
is proportional to the size.
So we're going to
scale, ultimately,
to get the correct
number of individuals.
It's just that you have to do it
some reasonable number of times
so that the randomness
kind of washes out,
and you end up approaching
that limiting behavior.
Does that make sense?
And indeed I just want
to mention a major result
in this field.
These niche type
models successfully
explained or predicted
another pattern
that had been observed, which
is the so-called species area
relationships.
So this is just saying that,
here, we looked at 50 hectares,
and we asked how many
species where there.
225 species in 50 hectares.
Now, the question is, if instead
of looking at 50 hectares,
we instead looked
at 500, do you think
of that the number of
species we observed
would have gone up, stayed
the same, or gone down?
Up, same, down, ready,
three, two, one.
Up.
If you look at a
larger area, you
expect to see more
species in a larger area.
And people really do this.
They look in some area, going
from, say, they take a meter,
and they count all the species.
And then they go and
here is 100 meters,
and they count all the species.
And they ask, how
many species do you
see as a function of the area?
And what people have found
is that the number of species
you observe it is proportional
to the area to some power,
where Z is around a 1/4.
And of course, the area
goes as some r squared.
If you wanted to,
you could say it
goes as the square root
of the radius, whatever.
But the number
species in some area,
it grows, but it
grows in a manner
that is less than linear.
Does that make sense?
It definitely makes sense
that's less the linear.
Because linear would be that you
sample a bunch of species here,
and then you look at
another identical plot,
you get some other species.
And they were saying that, oh,
that you really don't expect
any of those species overlap.
That would be a weird world.
So it very much make sense
that this is less than 1.
Of course, it didn't have
to be this power law.
But one thing that has been
discovered, around the world,
is that power laws
are very interesting.
But once again, many different
microscopic processes
can lead to power laws.
The niche models
have successfully
predicted or explained why
it might have this scaling.
But it turns out that neutral
models can also predict it.
And may just be that lots
of spatially explicit models
will give you some power
law type scaling that
looks kind of like this.
So once again, it's
a question of how
convinced you should be
about microscopic processes
based on being able
to explain some data.
And I think the best
cure for this danger,
of assuming that the microscopic
assumptions are correct,
because the model is able
to explain something,
is that, if you find some
other very different set
of microscopic assumptions that
also explain the patterns, then
it becomes clear that you
have to take everything
with a grain of salt.
And that's I think
part of what's
been very valuable about the
neutral theory contribution
to this field.
AUDIENCE: Does this
just come from-- you
assume that all the individuals
are uniformly distributed
and then [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There are
multiple derivations of this,
so it's a little bit confusing.
The neutral models,
that I have seen,
that lead to these
patterns, they basically
have the individuals
randomly, either
with sex or without sex,
kind of diffusing around,
and then they divide, deh-deh.
And then you can explicitly
just do the different spaces
and see that you get a scaling.
It seems to be a
surprisingly emergent feature
of many of these models.
And once again, it
may be something
that tells us less
about biology than it
does about math or something.
Any other questions about
this, the base notion
of this niche
hierarchy type models?
So I want to spend
some time talking
about this neutral
theory in ecology.
The math, in particular
the derivation
of this particular
closed form solution,
is not really so
interesting or relevant.
But I think it's very
important to understand
what the assumptions are in the
model and maybe also something
about the circumstances in which
we think that it should apply.
So the basic idea is that
we have, what we hope,
is some metacommunity
that is large.
And then we have an island.
So this has to do with this
theory of island biogeography.
We have an island over here.
And in the context of the
nomenclature of this paper,
they are some community
size, size j here.
This tells us about the
number of individuals.
And they're distributed
across some number of species.
Now, the neutral
theory, the key thing
is that we assume that all
individuals are identical.
And once again, it's not
that the neutral theorists
believe that this is true.
It's that they think that it
may be sufficient to explain
the patterns that are observed.
And when we say that all
individuals are identical,
what we mean is that the
demographic parameters are
the same, birth, death rates.
And it's even a stronger
assumption, in some ways,
than that.
It's assuming that the
individuals are the same,
the species are the same, and
that there are no interactions
within the species as well.
So there's no Alley effect,
or no specific competition.
So the birth, death
rates are going
to be independent of everything,
which is an amazingly
parsimonious model.
And it's kind of amazing you
can get anything out of it.
And then we have a
migration rate m.
It's either a rate
or a probability,
depending on how
you think about it.
Rate or probability m.
And can somebody remind
us how we handle that?
AUDIENCE: Both just
in a community?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At some
probability that
is proportional to the
distribution of the species
in the metacommunity?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: --transfer
an individual
from the metacommunity
to the island.
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: We do
stick to the island
to make sure that
number of individuals.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what we're going to
do is we're basically
going to pick a random
individual, here, each cycle.
This is kind of like
a Moran process.
We're going to pick
an individual here.
And we're going to kill him.
And then what we're going to
do is, with probability m,
replace that individual
with one member
of the metacommunity at random.
So the rate coming
from here will
be proportional to the species
abundance in the metacommunity.
And with a probability of 1
minus m, what we're going to do
is we're going to
replace that individual
with another individual
in the island.
Now, the math kind of gets
hairy and complicated.
But the basic notion
is really quite simple.
You have a metacommunity
distribution,
which is going to end up
being the so-called Fisher log
series in this model.
This describes the species
abundance on the metacommunity.
But then on the
island, we're just
going to assume that there's
birth, death that occurs over
here at some rate.
But we don't even have to
hardly think about that.
From the standpoint of,
say, a simulation or model,
we just run multiple
cycles of this,
where we have j individuals.
And we always have
j individuals,
because it's like
the Moran process.
At every time point,
we kill one individual,
and we replace it, with somebody
either from the same community
or from the island.
And you can imagine that in
the limit of m going to zero,
what's going to
happen on the island?
Yeah, so you'll end up
just one species, just
because this is just
random, like genetic drift.
It's ecological drift where
one species will take over.
Whereas if m is large,
then somehow it's
more of a reflection
of the metacommunity.
Are there any questions
about what this model
is looking like for now?
AUDIENCE: Could we talk
about the Fisher log series?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we would
put it on the same axis
as the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this is a
very, very good question.
So we'll do this
in just a moment.
Because this is very important.
I want to say just a couple
things about this model.
So when I read this
paper, what I imagined
is that it really
looked like this.
This was Panama, and that,
30 kilometers off the coast,
there was this island,
BCI, Barro Colorado Island.
But that's not maybe
an accurate description
of what the real
system looks like.
Does anybody know where BCI is?
AUDIENCE: It's in Panama.
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Panama.
PROFESSOR: So it is in Panama.
But it's not off
the coast of Panama.
I guess that was my original.
AUDIENCE: It's in the canal.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's in the canal.
So it's an island
that was created when
they made the Panama Canal.
So this thing was
not always an island.
It's been an island
for 100 years.
And it's in the
middle of a canal.
And they actually have cougars
that swim back and forth
from the mainland.
But it does make you
wonder whether this
is-- it's much more strongly
coupled to the mainland
then I imagined when I
read this paper at first.
I don't know what that
means for all this.
But certainly, you
expect this to be
a more or less appropriate
model depending on this.
Because, of course,
if you went and you
sampled 50 hectares
here, you wouldn't
believe that it should
have the same distribution.
You'd believe it should be more
like the Fisher log series.
And there's some evidence that
things are tilted in a way
that you would expect.
And we'll talk about that.
It's tricky.
And of course, you have to
decide in all this stuff, oh,
what do you mean
by free parameters?
And actually, it seems
like people can't count.
And we'll talk about
this in a moment, too.
Because, of course,
constructing the model,
there's some sense of free
parameters that you have there.
Because we could
have said, oh, it's
just going to be the Fisher log
series, or we could have said,
oh, it's going to be island.
Or we could have
said, oh, there's
another island out here.
And then that would be
another distribution.
And not all of these things
introduce more free parameters,
necessarily, because
you could say,
oh, this is the
same migration rate,
or you could do something.
But they are going to lead
to different distributions,
and you have that
freedom when you're
trying to explain the data.
There are a lot of judgment
calls in this business.
But let's talk about
Fisher log series,
because this is relevant.
So the model is very similar
to what we did for the master
equation in the context
of gene expression
and the number of mRNA.
So was the equilibrium
or steady state
distribution of mRNA in a cell,
was that a Fisher log series?
Yes or no, five seconds?
Was the mRNA steady state
probability distribution
a Fisher log series?
Ready, three, two, one.
No.
What was it?
It was a Poisson.
And you guys should review what
all these distributions are,
when you get them, and so forth.
So what was the
Difference why is it
that we have some
probability, P0, P1, P2?
This could be mRNA
or it could be
number of individuals in
some species with some birth
and death rates.
What was the key difference
between the mRNA model, which
led to this distribution
becoming Poisson,
and the model that we
just studied here, where
it became a Fisher log series?
And I should maybe write down
what the Fisher log series is.
So this is the expected number
of species with n individuals
on the metacommunity.
Here is the Fisher log species.
There was some theta X
to the n divided by n.
So what's the key difference?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think that the
birth and death rates are
both proportional [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, the
birth and death rates
are both proportional.
AUDIENCE: In the
Fisher log series.
PROFESSOR: In the
So what we have is that
b0-- and what should we
call b0 in this model?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well,
right now, we're
thinking about
the metacommunity.
AUDIENCE: Speciation.
PROFESSOR: Speciation.
b0 is speciation, which
we're going to assume
is going to be constant.
In this model, do we have
speciation on the island?
No.
The assumption is
that the island
is small enough that the rate of
speciation is just negligible.
So speciation plays
a role in forming
the metacommunity
distribution, but it doesn't
play a role in the model.
So this is speciation.
But then what we assume
is that b1, here,
is equal to some
fundamental rate b times n,
but it's b times,
in this case, 1.
So more broadly, bn is equal
to some birth rate times n.
This is saying that the
individuals can give birth
to other individuals.
Now, we're not assuming anything
about sexual reproduction
necessarily or not.
We're just saying
that the kind of rates
are proportional to the numbers.
So if you have twice
as many individuals,
the birth rate will
be twice as large.
This is reasonable.
This is Pn and
this is Pn plus 1.
So this is d of n plus
1 is equal to some death
rate times n plus 1.
So each individual just
has some rate of dying.
It's exponentially distributed.
This again makes sense.
What was the key difference
between our mRNA model,
from before that
gave the Poisson,
and this model that gives
the Fisher log series?
AUDIENCE: So with the mRNA, it's
with a standard like a chemical
equation where there's
some fixed external input.
But then the
degradation is according
to the amount that you have.
So death is proportionate
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
In both cases, the death rate
is proportional to the number
of either mRNA or individuals.
However, in the mRNA
model, what we assume
is there some just constant
rate of transcription,
so a constant rate, per unit
time, of making more mRNA.
So just because
there's more mRNA
doesn't mean that you're
going to get more mRNA.
But here, we assume
that the birth rate
is proportional to the number.
So that's what leads
to the difference.
And so this is one of
the few other cases
that you can simply
solve the master equation
and get an equilibrium
distribution.
And it's the same thing
we do from just always,
where we say, at steady
state, the probability fluxes
or whatever are equal.
So you get that P1
should be equal to P0.
and then we have a
b0 divided by d1.
And more broadly, we
just cycle through.
The probability of
being in the nth state,
it's going to be some P0.
And then basically, it's
going to b0 divided by d1,
b1 divided by d2, b2, d3, dot,
dot, dot, up to bn minus 1 dn.
And indeed, if we just plug in
what these things are equal to,
we end up getting-- there's
P0, the fundamental birth
over death to the nth power.
And then we just are
left with a 1 over n.
Because we're going to have a
2 here and a 2 here, and those
cancel.
A 2 here and 3 here,
and those cancel.
And we're just left with
the n at the end, finally.
So this x, over there,
is then, in this model,
the ratio of the
birth and death rates.
So which one is larger?
Is it A slash 1?
Is it b is greater than d?
Or is it b slash 2,
that b is less than d?
Think about this
for five seconds.
Do you think that
birth rates should
be larger than death
rates or death rates
should be larger than birth
rates or do they have to equal?
Ready, three, two, one.
So we got a number of-- it's
kind of distributed, 1 and 2's.
Well, it's maybe not that
deep, not deep enough.
Can somebody say
why their neighbor
thinks it's one or the other?
People are actually
turning to their neighbor.
A justification for
one or the other.
AUDIENCE: So if this
problem where b over d
is greater than 1, then this
distribution is not normalized.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if b over d is greater than
1, so if x is greater than 1,
then this distribution blows up.
Then it gets more and
more likely to have
all these larger numbers.
But then if b is less than d,
shouldn't everybody be extinct?
No.
Can somebody else say
why it is that it's OK
for b to be less than d?
If birth rates are
less than death rates,
shouldn't everyone be extinct?
AUDIENCE: Because
there's a rate b0.
PROFESSOR: Because there's
a rate b0, exactly.
So there's a finite
rate of speciation.
So it's true that every
species will go extinct.
But because we have a constant
influx of new species,
we end up with this distribution
that's this Fisher log series.
Now, if you plot the
Fisher log series,
it looks a bit like this.
But let's think about
it a little bit.
Does the Fisher log
series, does it fall off,
A, faster or slower than this?
Fisher falls, A, faster-- this
is in this direction-- or, B,
slower?
AUDIENCE: Faster or
slower than what?
PROFESSOR: Than the
island distribution.
Because you can see that this
falls off pretty rapidly.
Ready, maybe?
Three, two, one.
I saw a fair number
of people that
don't want to make a guess.
Indeed, it's going to be faster.
Can somebody say why?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Is it going to
be because of the 1 over n?
I mean the 1 over n
is certainly relevant.
Without the one
over n, then we just
have sort of a geometric series.
And the log normal is not just
a geometric series either.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Whereas
this has a very long tail.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this falls off.
This would be kind
of exponentially,
and this is faster
than exponentially.
And indeed, this make
sense based on the model.
Because this
community, the reason
that it has some very,
very abundant species
is partly because
it gets migration
from the abundant species here.
This falls off pretty quickly.
But those frequent species still
can play a pretty important
role in the island community,
because the migration rate
is influenced by large numbers.
And the other thing
is, of course,
that the rare species are
going to often go extinct.
I mean the distribution
on the island
is some complicated process
of the dynamics going here,
plus sampling from here.
But there's a sense that it's
biased towards-- it's not just
a reflection of
the metacommunity,
because the migration
rate is sampled
towards the abundant species.
So the migration
of these species
ends up playing a major role
in pushing the distribution
to the right.
So you have much more frequent,
abundant species on the island
as compared to the mainland.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
measurement of the distribution
on the--
PROFESSOR: Well,
I'm sure they have.
I think the statement
that there's a faster fall
off on mainlands
than on the islands
I think is borne
out by the data.
But I don't know if trees on
the Panama side of the canal
are actually better described
by a Fisher log series
as compared to this, though.
AUDIENCE: I guess my question
was the abundant species
that we see on the
island, is it just
the result of diffusive drift?
PROFESSOR: Well, this also
has the diffusive drift.
AUDIENCE: But in the sense
that what really pushes.
PROFESSOR: Well,
I mean I think you
need both, the diffusive
drift and the migration.
But I think that the fact
that the migration is
from the mainland,
and it's biased
towards those abundant
things, I think
is necessary or important.
AUDIENCE: I guess just in
terms of distinguishing
between the niche and
the neutral models,
as applied to the mainland, does
the niche model predict also
a log normal?
Because it seemed like,
in the discussion earlier,
the neutral also predicted
log normal [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
In this whole area, I mean
it's a little bit empirical.
The fact that the niche
model kind of predicts
this, or this broken stick
thing predicts a log normal,
they didn't say anything
about islands there, right?
I guess even Fisher's
original log series,
he used it to
describe-- I think maybe
that was the beetles
on the Thames.
But his original data set,
where the Fisher log series
was supposed to
described it, as it
was sampled better and
better, it eventually
started looking more and more
like a log normal anyways.
I mean it's easy to see
the frequent species,
because you see them.
This tail can actually
be very hard to see,
because you have to
find the individuals.
It's a good question of to
what degree each of the models
really predicts one thing
on one place and another.
There's always tweaks of each
model that adjust things.
So I think it's a bit muddy.
But the one thing that
I want to highlight.
So there's a lot
of debates, then,
between these different models.
And each of the
models have some fit.
They have red and black.
There's one that kind
of goes like this.
And another one that
kind of goes like that.
And they're not labeled,
because they look the same.
And you can argue about chi
squareds and everything,
but I think it's irrelevant.
They both fit the data fine.
And the other thing,
just the sampling of kind
root n sampling, if you
expect to see 10 species,
then if you go and you
actually do sampling,
you expect to have kind
of a root n on each one.
I mean the error bars,
I think, around this
are consistent with both models.
So I'd say that the
exercise of trying
to distinguish those models
based on fit to such a data
set I think is hopeless
from the beginning.
And then you can talk about
the number of parameters.
And if you read
these two papers,
they both say that
they have fewer number
of free parameters.
And it is hard to
believe that there could
be a disagreement about this.
But then, you know,
it's like, oh, well,
what do you call
a free parameter?
And then what they say, any
given RSA data set contains
information about the
local community size j.
So they say, given that,
it's not a free parameter,
because you put that in.
That's the number
of individuals.
And then outcome is your
distribution, right?
And you say, OK, well,
all right, that's
fine if you don't want to
call that a free parameter.
But then when you fit the log
normal to this distribution,
the overall amplitude
is also to give you
the number of individuals
in the metacommunity.
So if you don't call j a
free parameter in this model,
then you can't call the
amplitude a free parameter when
you fit the log normal,
at least in my opinion.
I think that they
both have three.
Because if you fit a
log normal to this,
you have the overall amplitude.
That's the number
of individuals.
And then you have the mean
and the standard deviation
or whatever.
From that standpoint, I
think they're the same.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I mean how
do you fit the log normal
when you don't impose?
Do they impose the amplitude?
I mean it's still a parameter.
PROFESSOR: No, that's
what I was saying.
It's a parameter.
I mean the normalized log
normal, you integrate,
and it goes to 1.
But then you have
some measured number
of individuals in your
sample, and then you
have to multiply by
that to give you.
AUDIENCE: But is that what
they do when they do their fit?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or do they keep that
amplitude as also a parameter?
PROFESSOR: I think that
you can argue whether this
is a free parameter or not.
But I think that
you can just put it
as the number of
individuals, and it's not
going to affect anything.
You could actually
have it be a free.
But this gets into this
question about what constitutes
a free parameter or not.
And actually, there is
some subtlety to this.
But I think, at
the end of the day,
the log normal is not
going to look like this.
You have to.
You basically put in the
number of individuals
that you measured.
AUDIENCE: So when you
calculate [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Huge
numbers of pages of
has been written about
comparing these things.
At some point, it comes down
to this philosophical question
about what you think
constitutes a null model.
And this gets to be
much more subtle.
And I think reasonable
people can disagree
about whether the null model
that you need to reject
should be this
neutral model or if it
should be a niche-based model.
Or maybe it's just that there's
some multiplicative type
process that's going on and
gives you distributions that
look like this, and you need
other kinds of information
to try to distinguish
those things.
And in particular, I'd
say that it's really
the dynamic information in which
these models have strikingly
different predictions,
and then you
can reject neutral-type models.
Because that neutral
models predict
that these species
that are abundant
are just transiently abundant,
and they should go way.
Whereas the niche-based
models would say,
oh, they're really fixed.
And indeed, in many cases,
the abundant species kind of
stick around longer
than you would
expect from a neutral model.
Of course, the neutral model
is not true in the sense
that different
individuals are different.
But it's important to
highlight that even
such a minimal
model can give you
striking patterns that
are similar to what
you observe in nature.
And so I think
we're out of time.
So with that, I
think we'll quit.
But it's been a pleasure having
you guys for this semester.
And if you have any
questions about any systems
biology things in the
future, please, email me.
I'm happy to meet up.
Good luck on the final.